it seems like every other major movie
these days is a prequel sequel remake or
reboot but they're not all just barely
warmed up leftovers some upcoming
remakes and reboots just might be worth
your time or dare we say blow you away
shocked in 1971 MGM released a film
adaptation of Ernest I demons detective
novel shock we're just talking about the
original shock
starring Richard Roundtree in 2000 per
melt remade the filmed with John
Singleton directing and samuel l.jackson
starring in the leading role and now New
Line Cinema is looking to release
another fresh take the new film has
blackish creator Kenya Barris and the
Goldbergs producer Alex Bonner writing
the script with ride-along director Tim
story at the helm hiring comedy writers
and directors may concern some shaft
Stanford producer Jon Davis says the
movie went strictly via comedy everybody
universals monster birth shed universes
are the big thing in Hollywood these
days and universal pictures of the
latest studio to get in on the action
but instead of turning to the comics the
inspiration the building a shed monster
universe a monster verse if you will
centering on the studio's iconic movie
monsters of old it all begins with Alex
Cartman's new take on the mummy starring
Tom Cruise and Russell Crowe hopefully
the finished film will have all the
sound unlike the botched first trailer
that never gets old
rounding out the monster verse is Bride
of Frankenstein with Javier Bardem
playing Frankenstein's monster Invisible
Man starring Johnny Depp an overhauled
Wolf Man with Dwayne Johnson reportedly
being eyed for the title role and you
then Helsing said to be in the vein of
Mad Max and finally Creature from the
Black Lagoon potentially starring
Scarlett Johansson and the female lead
not the creature of course she does have
the experience to play the creature if
need be Disney's live-action remakes of
the seeing enormous success with Tim
Burton's Alice in Wonderland in 2010
Disney commissioned more live-action
remakes based on their animated classics
like 2016 jungle book adaptation Beauty
and the Beast racked up record-breaking
grosses in March 2017 with a live-action
take on this story starring Emma Watson
next Jon Favreau will try to build any
success with the jungle book by remaking
the Lion King after that Disney's lined
up Mulan Aladdin karela Dumbo genies
Peter Pan Pinocchio tank The Little
Mermaid and a lot more all in live
action with an impressive collection of
planned problems like that at least two
or three might actually be good it
Stephen King's classic it was made into
a two-part miniseries for ABC in 1990
starring Jim Carrey is the monstrous
Pennywise the clown you get to offer a
scary of more lavish adaptation
Hollywood filmmakers have attempted to
bring the
life on the big screen for years beasts
of no nation and true detective director
cary fukunaga led the charge for several
years before dropping the project in
2015 following budgetary concerns with
New Line Cinema now mama director Andy
machete has taken up directing duties
with build skarsgård playing Pennywise
producer Dan Len likens the remake to
Netflix the stranger dings it's very
much in homage to eighties movies
whether it's classic Stephen King or
Spielberg The Crow several non superhero
comic book movies have done remarkably
well over the years including 1994's the
crows starring the late Brandon Lee but
for years
iWhat has tried to remake the crows to
no avail that may all be about to change
with Jason Momoa signed on to film in
2016 with the Hallows corin hardy
directed but with the remake having
moved from relative review media to
Davis films and renamed the crow reborn
there's uncertainty as to whether Momoa
and Hardy will remain on board will soon
know the film is finally scheduled to
begin production sometime in 2017 Escape
from New York said in a dystopian future
John Carpenter's 1981 classic Escape
from New York follows Kurt Russell's
Snake Plissken tasked with finding the
President of the United States after Air
Force one crashed lands in Manhattan
which the government has turned into an
enormous maximum-security prison Warner
Brothers has spent years pursuing
fruitless attempts to put together a
remake producer Joel so was the latest
to take a crack at it and he wants to
not only remake the film but turn it
into a trilogy
that's reportedly in the vein of Rise of
the Planet of the Apes and inspired by
the 2011 video game Batman Arkham City
of all things tomb raider aside from the
half dozen Resident Evil movies tomb
raider is likely the next most
successful video game movie franchise
ever made thanks to the - Angelina Jolie
films from the early 2000 Warner
Brothers is looking to reboot Tomb
Raider on the big screen with Academy
award-winning actress Alicia vikander as
Lara Croft and justified Walton Goggins
as the villain as gogans put it the film
will be like Raiders of the Lost Ark
genre version of the Joseph Conrad novel
victory and Island power so not much is
known about the story we do know it will
closely follow the gritty new video game
series which finds a young Lara Croft on
a quest to find a father
Lucian's eight after remaking the lowest
milestones original Ocean's eleven from
1960 Steven Soderbergh followed up with
two more successful installments but the
cast and crew opted not to make a fourth
film due to Bernie Mac's untimely death
instead of another sequel one of others
have decided to simply reboot the series
with an all-female cast Helms by a
Hunger Games director Gary Ross ocean's
8 will star here we go Sandra Bullock
Cate Blanchett Helena Bonham Carter and
Hathaway Dakota Fanning Rihanna
Sarah Paulsen's Mindy Kaling and Matt
Damon Damon is set to reprise his role
from the original oceans trilogy as
Linus cold well the film scheduled to
arrive in June 2018 thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]